.
7.5
In this presentation, I want to solve some of the discrepancies that
Contains multiplication and division of positive numbers and
Negative numbers, you will see it
Some deception is more than collecting and subtracting numbers
Which we saw in the last show
I also want to give you some other kinds of
The symbols used to describe the solution group are different
So let's solve a bunch of examples
Let's say I have -0.5x <
= 7.5
Now if these are adopted, it will be your impulse to say
Let's divide both parties on a coefficient
X phrase, this is quite logical to do
Divide both sides at -0.5
The important thing you need to realize is when
It deals with differentiated, ie when hit or
The two ends of the equation are divided by a negative number
It does the opposite
Reflect the disparate
Think about it that way
I will solve a simple example here
If you want to tell you that 1 <2, you think
You agree with me
1 No doubt less than 2
Now what will happen if both sides are hit by b
-1?
-1 vs. -2?
Well, 2-more negative
Of -1
If here, -2 actually less than -1
Now, this is not proof, but I think I will give you a sense of comfort
Towards the cause of the heart of the signal
If something is bigger, when we take a negative image of both
Ends, becomes more negative, or vice versa
So for that reason, if we want to hit both ends of this
Equation or divide the two ends of the equation on a negative number
We will need to turn the signal over
So let's hit both ends of this equation
To divide both sides by 0.5 is equivalent to multiplying by 2
The goal here is to get 1 parameter here
So let's hit both ends
Equation B-2
If we have -2 × -0.5
Maybe you'll say, how did you get these 2 here?
I'm thinking about what I can do
-0.5 In order to get 1?
And -0.5 equals -1.2
Inverted it is -2
If we hit -2
In this equation
I have 7.5 on the other side
I will also hit that with 2
And remember that when we hit or split the ends
We vary by negative number
Differentiated
We had less than or equal to
Now they are bigger than or equal to
If in the left side we have -2 ×
-0.5 = 1
We get x <= 7.5 x -2
That's equal to -15, a solution set
All x values ​​that are greater than -15 will achieve this equation
I challenge you to try and solve it with yourselves
For example, zero will succeed
0> -15
But try something else like - try-16
16. Will not work
-16 × -0.5 = 8, this is
Not less than 7.5
If the solution set is all x values ​​- let me draw the line of preparation
Here-> -15
That's the 15th, maybe that's -16
Those are 14
Greater than or equal to -15 is the solution
Now, maybe you will also see the solution sets for the discrepancies
Written in period format
It will take some time
To get used to
We will include 15, if less
For the period is -15
Putting it in this bow here means we will
We include 15
The package includes a minimum
Which includes 15
We will go down to infinity
And we put up brochures here
Arches naturally mean you will not include
the highest rate
Do the same thing for infinity, because infinity really is
Natural number
You can not just say, I'm infinity
You are not endlessly
That's why I put those brackets
But the brackets mean we will not be included
That limit, but we will also use it endlessly
So this and that are the same thing
At some times you will probably see icons placed, where it will be
So, you might be told that x is a real number
- That line, that is the vertical line
That means - x> = -15
These square brackets mean a set of real numbers, or
Set all numbers, where x is considered as real number
x> = -15
All this, this and all these are equal
Let us keep this in mind and resolve more examples
So let's assume that we have 75x> = 125
So here we can divide both sides to 75
Since 75 are positive, you do not have to
Variable change
Thus we get x> = 125/75
And if we divide the rugs and established on
25, we get 5/3
If x> = 5/3
Or we can write a set solution to start from 5/3 and include it
To infinity
Again, if we want to represent it on
Line setup, 5/3 km equivalent?
This equals 1 2/3
If we have 0, 1, 2, 1 2/3 will be
Here in this area
We will complete it
This is the 5/3
Anything larger than or equal to that will be included
In the solution group
Let us solve one last example
Suppose we have x / -3>
-10/9
If what we want to do is to isolate x on the left side
So let's hit both sides with 3, is not it?
Parameter, you can imagine, is -1/3, so
We will hit the inverted, it is
If we hit both sides by 3, we will get
-3 × - This can be rewritten as follows
-1 / 3x, and on this side, we have -10/9 ×
The disparate will fluctuate, because we
Multiply or divide by a negative number
So the variance fluctuates
It will move from a larger to less than
If the left side of the equation becomes x
That was the goal
This is deleted with this
Negative signs are deleted, x <
And then we have negative x negative
The multiplication factor is positive
Then if we divide rugs and denominator
On 3, we get 1 and 3, if x <10/3
If you want to type it in a period, the
Solution Set - The top solution is 10/3
It will not include 10/3
It's not less than or equal to, so we'll put
Quotations here
Notice here that it included 5/3
We put an arc
Here, we will not include the 10/3
We put the brochures
Will go from 10/3, down to the endless minus
Anything less than 10/3 will be included in the solution package
Let's paint it
Let's draw the solution set
If 10/3, we have 0, 1, 2, 3, 4
10/3 = 3 1/3, if he may fall - let me do that
In a different color--
Will be here
We will not include that
It's less than 10/3
10/3 does not fall within the solution set
That is 10/3 located here, and everything is less than that, however
Not include 10/3, located within the solution group
Let us solve another example
Suppose we have x / 15 <8
If again, let us multiply the two ends of this equation b
-15th
If -15 x x / -15
Then we have 8 x -15
And when we multiply the two extremes
With a negative number or divide both parties on a negative number
Differing reflectors
It's less than, we change it to bigger than
Now, this left side becomes x, because
These are deleted
x> 8 × 15 = 80, + 40 = 120, if
-120
Is this true?
80 + 40
Yes, -120
Or we can write a set solution that it starts from
120. But we will not include the 120
We have no equal sign here - down
To infinity
If we want to represent her, let me draw
Line up here
I'll draw one quickly
Suppose this is the 120
Maybe zero is here
This will be the -121
This will be -119
We will not include the 120, because it does not
We have an equal sign here, but it will be everything
Greater than -120
All these things that I do in green will be achieved
Differentiated
You can try it
Will zero succeed?
0/15?
Yes, this equals 0
It is undoubtedly less than 8
I mean, that did not prove to you, but you can try it
Of these numbers must succeed
Anyway, I hope you found this useful
I'll see you in the next show